all right teresa
and captain mike where are you guys from
original where'd you grow up
i grew up in atlanta the bronx really
yes wow tell me how you guys grew up
was nudism even part of your life when
you were children oh no when i was uh
16 my older sister who was 18 had a
boyfriend come to the house
and uh he couldn't go to her bedroom
they had to sit in the living room with
my mom sitting there with him so very
conservative
very strict catholic yes i was raised
southern baptist so you can imagine
oh wow yeah so is is nudism a reaction
to that
upbringing no not for me no not for me
it means
some kind of like
how did you first get introduced to it
some friends invited me to
a nudist resort in the area and i was
reluctant i kept saying no and then
finally i went
and it was kind of scary at first i'm
like oh oh and as soon as we drove
through the
gate to get in about the time i met up
with them they were out of their car
naked
i was like oh my thinking to myself oh
this is really happening
so i stripped down i went in and you
know of course in my mind i'm thinking
oh my god everybody's gonna know
nobody cared how long how long have you
been in nudist five or six years
oh so you're fairly new yeah and and
mike
how long have you been i actually became
a nudist by accident
i was living about 25 miles from here
looking for an investment
and i saw a condo on an auction site it
was a three-day auction so i put in a
really low bid and i came to see it
nowhere on the site did it say anything
about nudity well i came out here and
there are naked people walking around
and making people paying tennis
so i called the realtor he said i don't
know i've never been there i'm not going
there
he was afraid to come here so i thought
to myself well let me see if i can do
this i took off my clothes and i walked
around for a couple hours
yeah i could do this well come come to
three days later nobody else bid on the
place so i won the auction so i got a
condo when i wound up being a nudist
oh wow and what's this has been how many
years now
three years ago so this is fairly new
for both of you yes and
what's your impression of it we try not
to go off campus
we love it so much we keep putting
clothes on now we we schedule all our
chores so we can do in one day well i
can you know because there's today's a
saturday and there's a lot of things
going on people playing volleyball in
the pool there's a band playing people
dancing everybody and i mean and there's
a lot of people out there there's
probably more than
one or two hundred everybody's in a good
mood
oh yeah it's one level here in paradise
lakes can i mention the resort yeah
it's wonderful here every day there's
something to do we come up here early in
the morning we get a swim
we go in the hot tub then we go back we
do our stuff at home our errands she has
dogs she walks we have
day jobs from home we work from home
naked i'll be coming here in the
afternoon for another dip and then we
come up here and spend the evenings
we'll shoot some pools has your life
changed since you became noticed
since i'm like are you happier are you
less depressed are you anything like
that
oh yes my life is much fuller i can tell
you one thing i noticed
um outside the resort because there's a
residential part of it
there's a lot more people just milling
about all the time walking and jogging
and
you know on the golf carts making the
rounds um
and the place i lived before this was in
the textile world like you
really ever saw your neighbors but
everybody's outside i lived in my
previous home five years never met
neighbor
i was here one day everybody got to know
me everybody want to who know i am
where am i from all kinds of things
everybody looks uptight is the
impression i get of the world outside of
this resort
absolutely everybody seems so uptight
and here there's uptight doesn't exist
you know everybody's friendly everybody
wants to make new friends and have a
drink and talk and have fun
yeah and people are like you can just
feel in there you can see in the body
language their facial expressions they
everybody's having a good time and
there's no weird sexual behavior or
anything like that oh no or is that it
was uncomfortable at first a couple of
times i went in the pool and there was a
little girl naked in the pool and i
thought
i'm doing something illegal here i
should not i shouldn't be naked in a
pool
and the other side of the pool is a
little naked girl but it's it's just
natural to this is is there any
history of deviant sexual behavior with
with like you know
with k because there's a lot of kids
here yeah with children or anything like
that not none that i've heard of and
i i was the president of the hoa and
that's what's been around for how many
decades
38 years now yeah and there's it
wouldn't be existing today if there was
people have to separate nudity from sex
now there is a sexual element here they
have
one night a month they have their
parties or used to be two nights a month
before cover they'd get together and do
their
adult parties but other than that it's
just about is there is there a swinger
aspect to this
that's that's what i'm talking about
yeah yeah and it was one or two nights a
month now
now it's more private parties and homes
and they know who they are we're not
swingers
and they know it so they leave us alone
they'll chat with us they'll be friendly
but they don't advice to the parties
because we don't want to participate in
that right that's a whole other
lifestyle
right no you guys are married or you're
engaged you're engaged
so you just met here did you meet here
we met here in this pool three years ago
yeah so nudism has been uh a good
addition to your lives it sounds like it
has been very very good to me
yeah i mean your your energy your spirit
is is what i would
i would apply to everybody i've seen out
here you can just feel it the way they
look at you the way they smile the way
they everyone says hello
it's very pleasant here normally he
would be playing volleyball he played
volleyball pretty much every day naked
water volleyball they have sand
volleyball they have water volleyball
they have grass volleyball all kinds of
activities
i'm sure you guys have like dinners or
some kind of picnics whatever yeah now i
used to own a dance studio before cove
but i taught dancing here one night a
week
i thought naked salsa or naked cha-cha i
thought swingers had a swing dance
i taught hustlers how to do the hustle
yeah every thursday i would teach
dancing here yeah
wow and what what do your your friends
and family think of of your nudist
life well my a couple people my family
know
not everybody but most of my friends um
i'm in a
like a drinking globe running problem
and um they're actually the ones who
the people in there introduced me to it
so they don't care they know
although i live here do you think the
the way that most americans because it's
the united states i think that really is
the most uptight about
nudity europeans don't get uptight about
nudity but
in america we're like you see latino
countries are very uptight about it
because they're very very catholic
all of central america and i've traveled
around the world extensively
the the spanish countries they're
they're not ingenuity uh the european
countries are
as you mentioned um i mentioned i
noticed um i mentioned to one friend an
old friend of mine
that i was living in a nudist resort he
said to me how can you look at naked
people all day long
and i said harry it's not about seeing
nobody's looking here
it's not about being seen it's about
being no body image is like not even a
thing here
we have two women here who've had
mastectomies and they walk around with
scars
and nobody cares about i i've noticed
since i've been here
you're not judging anyone by their body
no no
you're judging them by their energy and
their their their pleasant mood
if anything right absolutely and for
little kids that come
and visit like grandparents or parents
they're usually european
the parents or grandparents europeans
are much more
at ease with yeah yeah it's almost
uptight americans though yeah
they can't handle it so all the
activities they have here you can do
nude if you want or you don't have to
they got pickleball and tennis and
so you could be clothed if you want to
oh yeah yeah it's yeah that's where it's
a little bit different
in the resort part anyway it's clothing
optional right not mandatory
yeah now some some resorts they require
you've been doing the pools
but here which one but as i was
explaining earlier we
live nude we come up to the resort nude
we go a lot of people will wear clothes
in between or no it's
kind of funny because you'll see people
doing everything but naked like yeah
mowing the grass
driving their car walking my dogs
rebuilding an engine
my record is 12 days straight without
putting on a stitch of clothes
really wow yeah and when you go to the
grocery store or whatever that you you
it's like you got to put on these stupid
clothes but they deliver now
almost everybody delivers right that's
right in the first couple of times they
come to the
bags of groceries and you're naked now
they don't care anymore the pizza guy
doesn't care
fedex doesn't care and this part of
florida is kind of the uh
the nudism capital of the country right
this county is the newest capital of
america
this county has i think 17 or 18
different nudist communities
some of them are private communities
just residential and some of them have
clubs like this i mean the weather of
course is a huge part of oh
absolutely it's in the county charter
maybe the only counter
county in the country it's right in
their county charter
that you can have nudist communities
and we go to a couple other ones around
yeah and there
there is i mean aside from the swinger
element of this
is there like a sexual
aspect to this or it's just it's just
more about freedom no more
what is nudism about no matter than
anywhere else if you go to a bar
on the outside you may be looking to
hook up with a girl
just like the bars here you may be i met
her here looking oh i i suspect there
probably is more deviant behavior with
people that are wearing clothes than the
ones that are like
well here you know you know what you're
getting yeah that's true
and that's the funny thing you mentioned
that so the resort when the nightclub
was open you know they would have
um parties each friday and saturday
night and
especially the women we want to look
sexy so we wear clothes or
not or you know sexy skimpy lingerie
yeah
because you know we're naked everybody
says
but you can definitely get away with
more than on the outside uh even when
you're drunk
you guys have kids i mean separately i
have kids i don't you don't
so so my your kids are what do what do
they think of
of dad and his newborn i have been three
years and they don't know yet
oh they don't know yet when they come to
visit i take them to disney for the week
i tell them daddy's house is not big
enough we're just going to go towards i
mean i i don't think it's anything to be
ashamed
no no it's not i i don't know
it's something to be proud of this is
new to me when i raised them i didn't
raise them to
where it was acceptable i had the same
payment as the rest of america
you keep your clothes on what do you
think that uptight aspect
the uptight attitude that americans have
about nudity is all about
i think it dates back to the puritans
yeah when they came across and
they were very strict religion and the
baptist came from that and
um very very we were born naked yeah and
we'll die naked
we're all dying we're probably in soup
oh yeah
yeah yeah it's very interesting you know
after after
extended periods of time without clothes
it feels uncomfortable to put cloth on
my body
it just it feels almost itchy i'm sure
yeah no clothes are
restrictive in the end right as as the
head of the condo association
i was required to interview new people
who want to move in renters or owners
and without fail every one of them when
i asked them what they expect to gain
from nudity
they all said the same thing freedom is
that what it's about
you know when you ride a motorcycle
people say what do you like about a
motorcycle
i feel free well you're not anymore free
on a motorcycle you just feel that way
same thing with nudity it doesn't make
me any more free than a guy with
clothesline
but it feels freer yeah because
that's that's the energy i get from
everyone that i see outside having fun
it's not like they're all a bunch of
perverts that are naked oh no not at all
it's it's it's more like they're they're
just free and they're free the baggage
of all that like you're supposed to be
this way you have to do that and you're
there's a lot of rules that we have to
follow as americans
when i explain to people who are coming
here i tell them in this community you
have the freedom
to walk around any way you choose to
what's the craziest thing you've seen in
the news
resorts crazy
i don't know i mean is there any so one
thing i noticed is there's a lot more
body jewelry than i would have imagined
on people older than me
if you're strangely yeah oh they're
right i've seen a lot of pierced
genitalia
men with pierced pimples and that that
surprised me we've got a guy who's in
his 80s
he's got five or six piercings in his
penis
why would he need that makes him happy
we call him jewelry and then his first
name yeah and when you say that
everybody knows who you're talking about
not hurting anybody no no maybe yourself
but not really
yeah that's just uh yeah again the
freedom to
pierce whatever you want to do yeah what
is nudism
what is this the last three five years
of your life
when you've been nudists what has it
taught you about what have you learned
from
from this for me personally being more
comfortable in my skin
you know because a woman i'll talk about
myself when i put on clothes like how
does this look how does that look you
know how does this fit
doesn't matter don't have that's what i
noticed is here
nobody's judging anybody's bodies no
nobody like the women that have maybe
whatever you know
we would deem as negative
you know trace of your body
yeah everybody's got a very relaxed
attitude they do yeah
that's nice and then we come to the
resort and you know we know
quite a few people who actually live on
property and then a lot of people who
are members and they come every day and
they just live outside the property and
just come here for activities
so it seems like like i would imagine
this it's pretty hard to get an argument
naked
yeah no it happens you have to
understand that
when you've been naked for all you
forget that you're naked that whole
that whole self-con consciousness goes
away i i don't feel any
protectiveness for myself because i make
it i'm not even thinking the fact that
i'm naked
in fact a lot of people tell me they
start driving off property without
realizing they were naked they had to
turn around and come back
they just they just didn't think about
it yeah you're it really
stops being an issue after a few weeks
of permanently being naked
or living naked well tell them a funny
story about you keeping track of them
so again when i moved here i was not a
nudist i don't know if you want to
include this but
for me it was it was kind of a thrill to
walk around naked in front of people so
the first we first i was here i'm
actually a kind of a nerd
i started a spreadsheet of how many
strange women saw my wiener
and for me it was the thrill that nine
people nine women saw my wiener today
the next day it was 12 women so am i now
i don't care
i don't even think about it you don't
even think about it but that first week
it was my head
i was doing this all day long looking at
you and and now
it's i've gotten over it yeah
yeah all right teresa and captain mike
thank you so much for sharing your story
you're welcome and go enjoy the weekend
out there thank you
thank you very much